last week as i was reading a
tweet that somebody had posted in
twitter about his
childhood and the fact that he was very
fortunate not to have been injured given
all the places he played
i had a lot of memories coming back to
me
about what it was like growing up in the
rural environment that
we moved out to when i was about
four or five out on the border of
wales and delafield delafield now is
pretty built up and actually the
subdivision that we moved into is now
like totally developed and even the
other areas that we played in are now
turned into these complexes of houses
and roads but it wasn't like that back
then
and you know i think for a lot of us
in the generation that i'm
in especially those who who grew up in
rural areas if you look back on it
we're pretty fortunate that we didn't
get more
injured or damaged or whatever you want
to
say then we did and so i'll tell you a
little bit about
what it was like and i'm not saying this
really to
you know to convey that there were a lot
of challenges in childhood or oh i'm so
lucky
or you know that our parents were
neglectful or anything like that
it's more you know i actually had a
really
enjoyable time much of of
my childhood except for you know clashes
with other kids and worries about that
and of course you know
my grandmother and my my dad dying
but the environment that i i grew up in
was
really quite you know quite nice in in
many respects and
i'll also say that in some other stories
i'll tell you about what it was like
in northwestern indiana at the time
which is where i spent
a you know a good portion of my summers
staying with my grandparents or my great
aunt and uncle
but i'm just going to talk about what it
was like growing up on glacier pass
so we moved into a
subdivision that like i mentioned was on
the border of
a township and a village the village
isn't much bigger than
than it was back then the village of
wales
and that's actually where i went to
school for my elementary school
and we even had a phone number that was
from a municipality
further south called genesee depot
that's how out in the sticks we were at
the time
and then there was delafield there was
the town of delafield
and then the township of delafield and
legally we were in the township so we
had
that kind of address but what it meant
was we were in
a subdivision and when people hear
subdivision they think of
suburbs and they think of these you know
sort of homogenous spaces and that's
that's not
really what subdivisions were like out
in the sticks at that time it was
something
where a farmer would have sold off some
property
that they just weren't using probably
had gone to to seed and go on fallow for
for quite some time
and it would get subdivided into lots
and then they would put kind of winding
roads that would go around and this is a
place where people would generally buy
lots
that were about an acre in size and then
build a house and we moved
out there in 75 and when we did you know
our house was
at least on the outside completely
finished but the yard was
of course like totally torn up and
needed to be
finished and we did that over years you
know putting down sod
planting grass doing landscaping all
sorts of things along those lines much
of which my dad
and i did together and um
the inside of the house was was in some
respects finished in other respects not
we didn't get carpet
in in most of the rooms for quite some
time and it was so cold that winter
that i remember my sister and i huddling
under blankets
uh by the the heat vents you know just
to stay warm but it was it was a good
place to be
and
the there must have been some sort of
economic
dislocation or disruption or something
like that because
very few people moved into the
subdivision right away we were one of
the first
um families to be in what was called the
hills of delafield right
and so you know our house was plunked
down and then there was
there were the schmidts and there were
uh
the shankies way way off in another
place
and i think there were a few other ones
but it took years
for the the lots to start to actually
sell
and people to start to build the houses
and something like a neighborhood
to actually develop and as it did
you know you would you would play with
the kids that were there unless
um they were you know too
problematic in one way or another there
were a few kids like that in the
neighborhood but for the most part
you know you'd play with the neighbors
that you had and i remember like walking
to
jeff van meter's house jeff was a year
older than me
and they also had a daughter in that
family
who is my sister's age my sister's about
two and a half years younger than me and
you know it was about a quarter of a
mile walk
i could walk down the road or i could
just walk right through the prairies
to where jeff lived and then he'd you
know knock on the door
ring the doorbell and ask if somebody
could come out to play and
you know playing was was basically
finding things to do
for for most of the day and
so you know i mentioned that that there
are a lot of things that could be
considered hazards let me
tell you a little bit about it but first
let me sketch out what the environment
was like
so that area is called um the cattle
moraine
area you know we were actually in the
kettle moraine school district
and kettles and marines are these these
geographical features
you know sort of like dips and hills and
all sorts of cool stuff so there's
there's all this not really rugged
terrain but there's like
ups and downs everywhere and there's no
like single
it's not like there's a single hill in
the middle of a plane it's just like
hills and valleys all over the place
and and uh it you know
it was wooded in many places and
prairie and other places with grasses
growing and lots of flowers
and you know you would find things like
old barns
and barbed wire fences marking off
certain areas
and quite quite a lot of the woods and
prairie were probably
fields originally that had just been
allowed to go go back to
the natural state that area
had been you know farmland for for quite
some time
and it just kind of you know went back
to nature
and so you'd find silos that were kind
of falling apart
and all sorts of cool things for kids
not particularly safe of course i mean
there were there were a lot of boards
that had you know old rusty nails so
our parents were i think perpetually
worried about us like stepping on a
rusty nail you'd hear about that quite a
bit
and then getting tetanus um and you know
it was it was interesting because
they're just you'd wander around and
that's what we did we got to know our
environment by
wandering along deer trails and
and other trails that got established
sometimes we had bikes to do so
sometimes you're just
hiking and we often made our own trails
as well
behind our house and most of the other
houses on glacier pass
there is this this large you know
ridge line you call it it's essentially
like a long
hill and it was all sort of forested but
it wasn't
it wasn't like old growth forest
necessarily although there were some
pretty big
oak trees in there and some other things
as well but lots of honeysuckle bushes
and sumac and you know you'd find random
stuff growing in in different places
at other at certain points the forest
got you know thicker and denser and
darker
and so we would just you know like i
said just wander
around and see what there was to see
in other places there were these cool
trails that that
went through the the meadows and the
brush land
and you know we would bike along them or
walk along them
and you know we would essentially
especially in summer
be turned out at after breakfast they'd
say all right
it's not raining we don't want to see
you until lunch get b
back here at lunch time and then you
know you'd have lunch you know wash your
hands eat some lunch
maybe have a snack or something as well
like an apple
you know drink plenty of water and then
they'd send you out again and you
wouldn't be back
generally until dinner time and the
adults were pretty cool with that so
long as they had some
vague idea of what you were doing and so
you know there were all these
territories that each had their own kind
of character to them
that we would we would explore and
like i said sometimes blaze trails or do
other things
along those lines and we would range for
miles and miles and miles
sometimes we'd get hungry and we'd you
know
take mullen and you know pull open the
the stalks and chew on the pith or if
somebody had a snack along we'd we'd
share it
although that was kind of infrequent if
we walked a long ways and we actually
had some money we could stop at
the kickapoo store and buy candy
or beef jerky or something like that but
it wasn't all that often that we
actually had any money so that wasn't
that wasn't done that frequently
and you know there were old rock piles
that farmers must have put together at
certain point sometimes we'd actually
find a
stone fence a lot of times we'd find
these these
posts that were almost you know falling
apart
with barbed wire stretching along them
and the barbed wire would be incredibly
rusty and sometimes
broken in places and we'd we'd push it
down or we'd hop over it
and so you know we like i mentioned we
ranged over a huge
area and the one thing that we were
generally told not to do
was to go on or cross the highway
there was a state highway 83 which
didn't really have that much traffic but
i suppose when it did have traffic you
really had to watch out because people
didn't didn't drive slow
along it and there was some truck
traffic
and we we weren't supposed to go across
that and we also were not supposed to
if we went down further we weren't
supposed to cross
highway 18 although we often did these
things as a matter of fact
i remember by the time that i was 10
years old
me and jeff van meter and jay laramie
riding our bikes all the way down
highway
83 to go to genesee depot
and you know kind of puttering around
there and buying some candy and then
coming back
up you know our parents would have been
very angry if they'd found out because
it was slightly dangerous but
you know you could sometimes be on that
highway and it'd be five minutes before
a car would go past
right across highway 83 was ethan allen
school for boys
which sounds kind of nice but was
actually
sort of like the maximum security
juvenile
prison so we were supposed to stay away
from that as well but of course we we
went down there
too not least because there was a really
cool hill that we could go down
and it was all wooded and so it was kind
of you know
nice and and temperature controlled and
dark
in in the summer but we didn't go near
the actual prison
and so this was what our our you know
summers and a good part of our
weekends and other times were like
exploring
you know finding out about nature i
probably learned a lot about woodcraft
through doing that every once in a while
you'd find wild fruits
that you know like blackberries for
example and you take your hat
and you just you know fill it up with
with blackberries parents weren't
usually happy about that because they
stained the hat
right but you know or you could do it
with your shirt again not not too happy
about that
and you know there was so little
supervision
that almost anything could have happened
you know i i'll tell you another
uh part about that at one point
there was actually a pack of wild dogs
that were going around
and there was another subdivision that
was much more established
it probably been founded in the 60s
across the highway
and they were attacking other dogs in
there and you know
a bunch of dumb kids we were told by our
parents don't go too far in the woods
don't go too far away
because you know you might run into them
and we just got a bunch of clubs
that we we made ourselves from you know
tree branches and and
we were like well if we run into the
dogs we'll take care of them obviously
if we had we probably would have been in
real trouble
but very little you know very little
happened i mean sometimes you twist your
ankle and
be a while before you could get up or or
there'd be
times when you might do something dumb
and get the wind knocked out of you
we also did have rock fights every once
in a while
i remember getting hit by by a rock here
and you know bleeding quite a bit
and then like you know beating up the
kid who'd thrown the rock
but for the most part you know it was um
pretty it was pretty safe remarkably
safe what we were doing given all the
kind of crazy stuff that we're doing
again with no adult supervision
just on our own sent out to explore
the the natural environment and to
explore these these old decrepit
you know barns and silos and places like
that and i remember
really enjoying that i think that's
where i got
a lot of my love for hiking
from and uh learned a lot of
woodcraft not by somebody actually
teaching me saying boy scouts or
something but
just by observing after a while you kind
of know how trails go and what to look
for and
what plants do what and
yeah so that was something
you know quite quite remarkable when you
look back on it i think there's many
other kids who had
similar childhoods and could tell
similar stories um but i think that
nowadays i know that this is also the
case for for me and my kids you know
when they were little
i wanted to know where they were all the
time because we're we're in a very
different environment where
um there are seemingly so many more
dangers and challenges
and we want to keep track of things much
more
so it was really a a different time and
a different way of growing up and
you know i think there's plenty of
people who live like that today but
i think that maybe a lot of kids miss
out on that
and miss out on the opportunities that
being able to
wander day after day after day over
large portions of territory actually
provide so there's my story there's
really not much more
to it other than to say that
occasionally you know we did get hurt
but fortunately none of us got
hurt to the degree that did any really
lasting damage i will say one other
thing as well
often times the getting hurt would
involve
being on a bike and try to do something
kind of silly with the bike you know we
had dirt bikes and
go down hills that were a little bit too
steep and then wipe out and
you know you get banged up and all that
none of us had helmets none of us had
you know elbow or knee pads or anything
like that so we're probably fortunate
that we came out more or less okay
you